We have a certain intuition about
what objects will feel like, and
what we can do with them,
just by looking at them.
We call these affordances.
Take for example,
this piece of paper, and this apple.
I know from my previous experience with
paper that I can easily pick it up.
I can twist it.
I can tear it, and so on.
I know that the apple has greater mass.
It'll be harder to pick up,
but that I can throw it up or
even take a bite out of it.
Now these learned expectations
help us to quickly recognize
how we can interact with objects.
Now completely recreating real world
objects in our UIs can be limiting and
have some adverse affects.
We can, however, take advantage of some
of these basic principles of affordances
and tangibility to make
our UIs more intuitive.